welcome back to GameSpot's III 2014
coverage here live from the show floor
I'm your host Chris waters and last week
I had a very special opportunity travel
to a wonderful place a moon filled with
horrible love of demons and crazy
psychos that wanted to kill me here to
talk about Borderlands the pre-sequel
with meet Joel from 2k Australia and
James from gearbox gentlemen welcome to
the stage excited to see you again we
had a rendezvous in San Francisco last
week where I got to play the game which
was a lot of fun I think it's the
borderlands I know and love but not
quite there's some new stuff going on
you guys taking us to the moon yeah I
mean people have been wanting to go to
the moon for the longest time like even
before we got involved in the game we
were seeing messages on on--for oh say
when are we going to be able to go to
the moon in the moonshot facility so it
was really awesome for us to be able to
work with gearbox and finally fulfill
that promise of going to to the moon and
go into the moon shop facility and
seeing some of Jack's origins and of
course another one of Borderlands
players perhaps dreams or odd fantasies
to play as claptrap right yeah that was
something that also in the forms we've
been seeing a lot of interest about like
you know quirky ideas with characters
you know we had a really kind of pushed
our boundaries when we had made Krieg
and so we knew that we kind of want to
do some more experimental character
design and so when we were deciding to
do this story we thought well let's try
this out you know let's try to do
something really cool here very cool
well you guys have brought a bunch of
gameplay footage for us to check out so
we're gonna fire that up shortly folks
we are going to take your questions via
GameSpot hashtag GameSpot III or just
right in the GameSpot chat I'll be
checking them out but let's talk about
first let's run through the four vault
hunters cuz yeah I know you guys aren't
talking about all of them and all their
glory yet you're holding back on us but
Athena is one of the new ones and she's
got that shield yeah FINA she was from
the secret army of general Knoxx DLC
from bullets one people folly remember
her and her action skills she has this
kinetic aspis which allows her to absorb
damage from enemies and as you go
through her skill tree and actually
sorry it gets really cool but we're
looking at Wilhelm right now I realized
so let's switch gear
real quick and talk about Wilhelm cuz
now oh wait are we playing as it looks
like we're playing as Athena you're a
celestial enforcer
that's the Wilhelm class alright so
let's talk we'll help
sorry alright yeah you know so fans from
Borderlands 2 will know that Wilhelm was
really like the first big boss fight we
kind of built him up as nameless like
this really dangerous enemies and you
know you fight him and he's this massive
guy that's more machine than man yeah
not a dude like in any way he's like a
huge loader right but we didn't want to
start off with him that way and the
pre-sequel we want to kind of show like
an evolution with them and also we well
did they become give something for the
players that be invested in so he starts
off more man than machine now but
depending on where you put your skill
points you can actually put physical
augments on him that will replace parts
of his body so you can get stronger legs
you can get a pneumatic arm that will
kind of shoot out and punch you get the
Vengeance cannon was a big thing on a
shoulder that was shooting up shooting
death at you and be able to so you have
the sort of option this opportunity to
transform him into that guy yeah and
that and it reflects on his character
model you know you see it you see the
Robo arm come out which is really
satisfied it's not even it's not just
that it's that whenever you actually put
the skill points into them you will see
him immediately change in the menu so
players can see how their choices are
impacting him and we just saw the arm
right there punching apart one of these
I would keep wanting to call the moon
Scaggs but there's actually another name
for them yeah these are the Krakens
their dragons these moon beasts and
because this is Borderlands you know
they kind of absorb elemental attributes
from the moon in this particular map
you'll see we have this liquid methane
which does kind of cryo damage to the
player and these break-ins are the same
day they can kind of shoot cryo damage
towards you and it's really cool you'll
see here when you see some of the bigger
ones like the Avalanche then actually
burst into smaller little mini Cragen's
that then come to attack you and
sometimes our designers I don't know how
deep they actually take it how many
times you can shoot them - how many Krag
ins actually come out to attack you yeah
you come across a badass crag on you
might be getting into a real Russian
Russian nesting doll invasion exactly
it's really cool because you might go in
and you see one of them and facial
initially go oh it's just one on one no
problem but then becomes two on one then
401 then six on one depend on how big
they are it could get really big and
we're taking a look at footage from the
PC version of Borderlands the pre-sequel
now I could tell that because there's
all of these particles flying everywhere
and that which is really satisfying the
freeze the enemy with cryo damage and
then smash apart and like yeah the low
gravity float away yeah yeah I'll do
that to any enemy we built this system
to procedurally freeze baddies and then
you do a bit more damage if you me lay
them but you can shatter them through
bullets as well but just any enemy once
you get them down low enough you can
then burst them open it yeah it is
pretty beautiful seeing the ice shots
kind of flowed off into the distance
something that you're that Joel and this
team did a really awesome job on it's
like the way they shatter also it's not
just about the fact that they
procedurally shatter it's that they will
shatter along the trajectory that you
killed them so if you slam down on them
the particles are going to go down to
the ground and then off to the side if
you're cutting them then they will cut
in half and break off in the chunks that
way whatever direction you shot them
from they will shatter that directa it's
really cool let's talk about that phrase
you just used slam down on them because
this is something that's new to
Borderlands and I think you actually
misspoke and you meant to say butt stomp
oh I mean I don't correct you that's a
little embarrassing but the designers
hate me when I go home because it's
called a slam but I have to call it a
bus stop that's just what naturally
comes to me but like what when you are
in low gravity you can see your junk
being like you know 30 50 feet even
sometimes you can get hundreds of feet
up into the air I don't actually know
what a foot is we use the metric system
in Australia but I think it's really
high time are you jumping these massive
distances going really far and you can
hold the crash button and you bust off
you slammed down to the ground you do
this area of effect attack and you can
actually apply like elemental damage so
if you jump from high enough to the high
you have to do it from the mold damage
you're gonna inflict you can actually
jump down slam it freeze an enemy and
shatter them in one go and if you manage
to land on top of someone you actually
split them down the middle and so you
just have ice particles kind of flow it
out now I'm just picturing you guys
having some kind of screenshot contest
let's say what kind of sculptures you're
making with the shattered show
cards of your enemies so don't tell me
if you don't do that I want to live in
that fantasy world where that's a thing
ah now you're being shot with lasers
here lasers is sort of a new which is
called a weapon type yeah it's a weapon
type yeah you have any mo types of
lasers as well it goes across the the
entire weapon spectrum so because of the
procedural weapons system in Borderlands
you know you have this ridiculous amount
of lace you now have each of the
manufacturers have their different
attributes so you have your beams you
have your fault lasers you have
different reload types and everything
and they can also have elemental damage
attached to them so you can have like it
an ice beam where you can be shooting
this kind of Ghostbusters style beam at
someone and freeze them and then see
them shatter at the same time
well you said Ghostbusters and now I
have no doubt that there's gonna be some
mission somewhere in the game where you
guys just lean real heavy into the
Ghostbusters references we got a
question coming in over Twitter from
darkblade 12 wondering about will there
be new legendary items in the pre-sequel
and of course that loot collection so
integral to Borderlands what do you guys
do it with the pre-sequel yeah I mean
we're we're not no in addition to adding
the elemental and in addition to adding
lasers we're also adding new gear in
general so players can expect to have
you know new uniques from from missions
and bosses and new legendaries as well
excellent let's talk about we've talked
about Wilhelm and sort of you know the
the wolf Saint drones we see they're
active flying around right now it just
disappeared quickly about the other
active skills you guys have talked about
cuz of course that's what makes a vault
that's one of the main things that makes
each character unique is that skill
we're talking about Athena before for
shield the aspis which can absorb damage
the thing I really liked about it is it
absorbs elemental damage if you get the
right perk and it creates these
concentric rings mmm it look really
pretty that was actually something that
we very recently add to the game so it's
cool for me to see in the demo as well
well you can get I some shock in a fire
and deal it back and if you get the
wrath of the goddess skill you can
ricochet it across multiple enemy sets
them on fire let's treat them all at the
same time as you said Wilhelm has his
two
often seen so the way his skill trees
work the the left one is all about a
Korean wolf who's son of an attack drone
so you can give him you know make him
stay alive longer or give him missile
barrage as you can get him to kind of
chemical Z as your action school runs
out the right skill kind of levels up
saying to buffs you and heals you you
also can do more damage through
elemental and when you're in low gravity
jumping and things in the center one
side of the commandos James was saying
all about turning into that robot that
you were in Borderlands 2 yeah and then
the other two vault hunters we mentioned
claptrap who you guys are keeping your
traps clapped about as of now maybe
Gamescom will hear a little bit more
about it
I mean people should definitely stay
tuned yeah we're gonna be showing you
more of the game are actually gonna
inventing tiny new games convention just
just for claptrap actually alright seems
like he deserved it
and then the fourth Nisha the law
bringer glass who you guys are also not
talked too much about but I presume it's
some sort of pistol related to oil thing
based on what work we've seen upper the
demos which hasn't been too much that
was like a good idea
yeah and we're obviously building off of
the characters that people know I think
people that can infer a good deal about
her and so yeah characters people know
you got you know some a lot of these you
know all these vault hunters have had
some appearance in Borderlands before
but in the trailer you guys released
last week we caught a glimpse of Lilith
you know I think it's safe to say like a
bunch of original vault hunters we saw
Bob see a bunch of the characters aren't
gonna be back for the sequel pre sequel
yeah we have all of really I think cool
cheeses and the trinda in the trailer
that people pay Kenai they can notice
quite a bit in there yeah being set in
between Boylan's one two there's a lot
of story to tell like not just for Jack
and the vault hunters but there's a lot
of kind of gaps in in characters
timelines and there's a lot of
fanservice in there
all right well we're gonna be wrapping
up a in a little bit now but let's talk
about something we haven't really gotten
into we talked a bit about low gravity
and sort of how you can get to these
Heights and do the slam move down but
let's talk about oxygen that's the o2 is
the third bar you see there in the
bottom left corner because that's a
resource you got to be mindful of now
and it's also a tool you can use to fuel
a couple abilities yeah so we had an
idea in mind of what the moon would be
like you know we wanted to be similar to
our moon because we always kind of
imagined it being that way and so we
know that would involve an atmosphere
and so we wanted people to feel that
that's sort of that that danger of
running out of options but we also
wanted to because not be there's like
this annoying a resource that you
constantly have to manage so like yeah
you are losing oxygen but we have plenty
of opportunities like that cracking the
ground with that sort of shimmering
effect of it that's a that's releasing
oxygen all the time so if a player sees
one of those they can easily refill we
will also want the option to kind of
feel purposeful you know so we wanted to
be fun so that's what we added in things
like the slam attack and the double jump
the extended jump there's actually
something that we we showed a little bit
of in the demo which is that you can
actually revive your play of your other
co-op buddies with oxygen and so we've
won that it kind of creates a meaningful
decision you can do with this new with
this new feature enemies they have to
have oxygen as well you can burst the
domes which go over their head so that
kind of brings some of tactics into play
of how you want to encounter different
spaces because you aren't gonna burn
enemies aren't gonna burn when you get
back you so you can decide to bring
oxygen there you have a really good
laser that does fly damage then you're
definitely gonna want to turn that off
very cool well it looks like you guys
are really doing a lot to you know
preserve that thing that makes those
things that make Borderlands the
Borderlands we know and love but also
bring some new stuff in I imagine that's
a bit of a challenge for you guys but
you seem up to it thanks for coming on
and showing it off thanks my friends the
pre-sequel tell us when it's coming out
and what platforms it come to October 14
this year in America then the rest of
all is October 17
fantastic Joel James thank you so much
for coming on stage have a great